[Music]  [Applause]  momentarily lost brown who gets into the  paint  then lays it in there you go that's good  offense  [Music]  gonna reach in by harris i think she'll  score continuation  [Applause]  shooter  [Music]  pretty good position bounce pass  and foul  [Music]  watch this pass  i mean brown's not even in your screen  but watch it as he gets there  and just the power  [Music]  three-point play opportunity smart  brown  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  comes off  stop pop  money gets the defensive stop  brown  with the ball ground behind the back  domination  al in transition  for the win let me do this behind my  back  yes  [Applause]  why not why not is right everything else  is working why not that